ladies and gentlemen roland
emmerich uh
as roland sits i just want to say a huge
thank you to lionsgate and imax for
uh doing this with collider this is our
first screening in two years
uh due to covid and i just want to thank
you for doing this with us uh
you're very welcome thank you and well i
know you've also been promoting for the
last few days non-stop and i know that
uh
you know coming to do more talking is
not necessarily you know top of the list
but thank you okay
uh so uh i have a ton of questions and
let us get started and i believe we are
all set you're also on facebook live by
the way so
no
i'll probably curse who's kidding who uh
so i like throwing some curveballs at
the beginning if someone has actually
never seen any movie that you've
directed what's the first thing you want
them watching and why
they should just lean back you know
enjoy the movie you know with a good
kind of you know like bucket of popcorn
no but i mean what's the first movie of
yours that they should watch if they've
never seen anything that you've done
oh
maybe stargate
is yours that's a good start right
uh which of your films changed the most
in the editing room compared to what you
thought going in
um
i think that was like 10 000 bc
that was like kind of uh that was like a
tough
movie to cut down
you know just like you know because of
the endlessly long you know like kind of
travel shots we had etc etc and to bring
this down to the
lengths you know it was necessary that
was
quite a challenge did you have like a
crazy long first cut that you yeah was
like three hours
all right i suppose like even for me too
long you know i said where can we cut
out some
some shots
uh what was the final running time on
that one do you remember i think it was
like two hours and 15 or 10 or 15
something like that so there's a lot of
stuff on the cutting room floor yes
yes yes yes yes if uh i read and i could
be wrong i read that you were interested
in being a production designer and then
you went to see star wars and that sort
of changed your life
no okay everything you read on the
internet is not true it's not true
exactly i was actually already on the
film school
i just had signed up and
in the same year
two movies came out in fall
in europe
one was star wars and one was close
encounters of the third kind and that
kind of some sort of uh not made me you
know all of a sudden want to do
something different it was like a three
or four or five year process
which did that
so
do you remember did you what was your
reaction when you saw star wars
you know when you were much younger did
it have like a real profound effect well
it had a profound effect and uh also had
uh uh close encounters you know i mean
that deeply deeply impressed me and i
actually uh
shied away from directing
because of that because i i just
couldn't believe that i will ever be
some sort of okay director you know and
when you like kind of and when you like
do a production design you have always
like you know you try to make it look
good and that's that and
and it took me a while i think it was
like a joey when i kind of started to
think you know it's my second film joey
i kind of thought
maybe kind of i should do this you know
but only when i came to america i kind
of thought okay this is like it you know
um
now i have to direct two or three movies
and then we'll see
what was it like for you then
having these sci-fi movies have such an
impact on you when you started directing
sci-fi was there like a day on one of
the sets that you're like i can't even
believe i'm doing this
well it's like
look it's it's uh for example my uh
graduation film
does as you know principe is the only
movie i ever shot in german
and you know and at the very beginning
there were four
students who wanted to all put their
money together
and
uh one by one they're all dropped out
and i was like kind of supposed to do
the production design so i kind of took
over the directing you know production
design directing
and i ended up in the uh the berlin film
fest you know in competition
with that film
and it was like kind of such a such a
out of
body experience for me
that i uh kind of said okay um and i
remember there was like kind of um
there was like kind of the
big big uh
you know 200 journalists
and they had just like finished the
other um
you know um
uh press conference and it was for i
think it was for um
whoever whoever it was you know there
was jack nicholson sitting there
jack nicholson was sitting there and i
was for sure not sitting in the same
chair so i i said totally on the outside
and then the first question was um how
old are you guys you know and i said
well old enough
it was like just a huge laugh and then
you know um there was that you know and
i remember that you know my parents
always said like what are you doing
constantly on tv
they said like this is like really odd
you know they felt it very odd you know
that their son is and
there's so much interest about me
you have directed over 20 films which of
those was the hardest to get financed
and why
um
wow it's just like i i never really had
problems to get
a movie financed
um because um
so far
so good because uh look it's like uh
everybody like says midway was a a total
disaster but it wasn't you know uh i
think that the equity investors are two
million away from breaking even that's
very early so they will make like six
seven eight nine million dollars
you know on this movie and uh and i
think uh you know when you do this right
you know then you don't have that to
make that much money
because uh it's it's it's a it's it's a
thing you know where people like say oh
this has to make two or three times that
money in the theaters but it's not true
that's not true you're telling me that
hollywood lies about finances no that
they they
make their movies too expensive
and they make their movies you know that
that
spend too much on advertisement
because a movie is like either good or
mediocre or bad
and they it will anyway happen as it
will happen so you know it's like just
uh
you know the truth you know and and when
you like kind of uh are
i mean i had like for example for this
uh movie
158 million dollars right
and uh 11 million goes alone
away for
financing
then you have to spend one and a half
million for the completion bond
and then we had like six uh no 5.6
million in covet cost
that all goes off the movie budget and
then you have like 118 million dollars
and that's what you have
and that's you have to deliver it
i appreciate you what's funny is not
everyone is willing to talk about
numbers and i i really appreciate you
talking about it because it's like kind
of i mean it's this kind of thing you
know nobody talks about it but it's like
kind of i think that's uh that's wrong
you know also i have the feeling you
know um
you know um
that's you know um
it's super hard these days to get a
original ip going you know i mean just
original ip you know it can be
anything you know if it's like a comedy
or anything and when you like look at it
it's it's very rare that uh original ips
have any chance anymore
yeah i'm not to bring in another movie
but i think about what sean levy did
with free guy this year opening
something that you know was based on
nothing
you know it's it and it's rare for the
studios to even make these movies yeah
but like they're only like kind of well
made by fox
you know it was made fox exactly what
fox had like enough still a knack for
original programming
i wanted uh but not anymore that's
people yeah that's uh yeah i won't open
that door
so you a lot of filmmakers go back and
revisit some of their older movies and
like will tweak it or make an extended
cut or fix some vfx do you have any
interest in actually going back and
looking and tweaking any of your older
movies doing a new cut of it or are you
sort of like these are in the past i
don't want to touch these
well they're like kind of uh they are
what they are you know what i mean
why fixing them i mean i understand that
like lucas at one point wanted to go
back and fix some stuff but i don't
think he made it better
i would agree with you
so you know why
you're not doing that i mean it's uh the
movie is what it is and then you know
you make your next one
before we get into moonfall my last
thing uh i i want to sort of do a little
bit of a word association with you with
some of your some of some of your movies
and i would like you to sort of mention
a word or two when you think back on
these films whether it be you know
because of the shoot whether it be
whatever it whatever it is so when i
mention universal soldier what do you
think
uh running down face forwards to who uh
the hoover them
stargate
seeing you know
seeing
a pyramid land a spaceship land on a
pyramid
uh independence day
uh will smith's knocking out the alien
godzilla
a movie i never wanted to make
[Laughter]
can can you elaborate
oh it was like it was like kind of one
of these things where i did everything i
could to not make the movie
and
everywhere i whatever i did i kind of
you know um
i failed i made them slimmer i made them
faster
it didn't look at all like the original
godzilla
and
uh and yeah and that i like i always
said yes yes yes
yes yes
uh the patriot
um there was about one scene you know
where mel shows his real face and that's
when he gobbles the
you know the when he beats the
head of the
thing over and over and more and more
blood spritzes in and we like see his uh
three sons you know
what he has three sons
uh
looking at him like they don't know
their father anymore
the day after tomorrow
um there was like a scene in there where
like kind of just see a ship going
through
uh fifth avenue and that was pretty cool
um i'm actually gonna start i'm gonna do
one more uh i'm gonna do stonewall
um misunderstood
okay
uh
have you ever oh no i want to skip that
uh people love watching the end of the
world movies um what is it about the
genre that you think people
like keep coming back to it
something that people love watching
um
first of all um even the bible ends with
a big catastrophe
and
when i did independence day there was a
huge destruction sequence in there
and i really realized you know i'm on to
something
and i
somewhat created my own genre
you know because when you like have uh
when you can um
you know have an alien invasion
and you and there is room for something
like that
that's always great
and uh it starts with
a white house exploding and ends with
boomer jumping into safety
and that was like a six or seven minutes
sequence
and the people were just speechless
speechless then and i kind of thought
okay cool
then you know maybe um
uh
2002 or 2001 i was like kind of had a
script for day after tomorrow
and i tried to make it look as much as
independence day as possible
and actually tricked hollywood because
they bought something which they later
regretted
and but it was a big hit for them but
they felt uneasy about it and they were
like kind of stunned at the success of
this movie
i know i know a lot of people that
really love day after tomorrow oh yes
and it's uh it's a i think it was ahead
of its time but
what can you say uh and
nothing has changed any anyway
politically so
uh that's for sure
and yeah and this was like kind of and
then you know then i said i make now my
last uh you know um
disaster movie that was 2012
the movie and
and i packed everything in there
everything that i ever could come up
with was in this
movie and yeah and that was that and
then you know i read all of a sudden uh
a book called who built the moon
and so it's an english book by two
writers and uh and i said hmm what's
that
but i needed like three or four
five years to get used to the fact that
i'm making a disaster movie again but i
had it play mostly in space
you know what i mean when you look at
the movies first uh all the race to get
into space and then it stays in space
until the very end
and only in the cut by what's happened
to the family
i i want to go backwards though um what
every movie changes from when you first
start out to what people see on screen
what were like some of the dramatic
changes that moon fall went through uh
when you were putting it together
it was just too long
that was like kind of one of these
movies where i had a really long script
and we had to hone it down but the
moment you well we had a problem we
couldn't test
at the very beginning they didn't let us
test
so we tested actually too late
and
and then we realized all of a sudden
well the people are much more interested
in space than they are in
destruction on earth
that's what was the overall uh
thing and they they
you know they they were more interested
in what's happening in space and that's
what we did you know we like kind of
then more and more uh
had like kind of the focus on um on the
space part
you mentioned earlier that you had like
your 10 000 bc was three hours your
first cut did you have a much longer cut
of moon fall no no no it was like under
135 minutes or so
you have um the third act of this movie
is loaded with vfx and you mentioned
that you obviously have a budget you
have a
you have a lot of money but you don't
have an unlimited amount of money how
can you sort of talk about the
challenges of making a film of this like
spectacle on the budget that you had
well the first thing is uh i shot the
movie in 61 days
that's a very very rare occurrence
there was no second unit
i kind of actually directed both units
uh the main unit and then uh something i
call the splinter unit
and
we i had to cut out like eight or nine
days from my shooting schedule
and it was already very short by the way
you know and um
that was the first thing and then
um
we had like a line producer who always
like lied to us
uh because i said oh we're like out of
money oh we're out of money and then at
the end we had like kind of four and a
half million left
and that was good because we needed that
for the visual effects because they
naturally were much more costly
well you as i said the third act when
you i don't want to do spoilers because
we're live but the third act you go into
the moon there are some very complicated
vfx shots um you know and obviously
those are not for things like this
is it
how does it work in terms of the behind
the scenes on the cost when you're going
to like a studio whatever double
negative or whoever it may be how does
it work in terms of if you don't mind
talking about it like the negotiation of
how much things will cost going in
versus what it actually is does it
change a lot in post well what do you
what you do is like you try to lose
stuff
overall and then pack it into the third
act that's most of the time what happens
you know there is a lot of lot of little
stuff which you can just lose right and
then you like concentrate uh from the
middle on to the to the end
and that what we did too the only kind
of uh um
the only um
the opening scene was exactly what it's
supposed to be
and then we had to anyway cut down time
because everybody wanted to get them
have them go up into space
and then when they're in space you know
you like kind of have to spend the money
and we had we didn't had enough money
but then because our line producer was
lying to us we had money and we like
used it very carefully
uh
you've talked about in the past that you
were surprised that nasa was willing to
put their name on this what were you i
mean i'm a little bit surprised because
it does have like a conspiracy theory
about the moon
so what was your reaction actually when
did you find out nasa was going to be
involved and were you like wait well it
was like kind of officially sent to nasa
to support it
and i said will never not happen right
and it happened
i think they changed their whole tune
you know because
now because they
probably see like kind of movies in a
different way they have also like a a i
think a different
um guy who's like running
that kind of thing and bird and he um
when he's like kind of super relaxed and
he he said to us like it's very simple
certain things you cannot show and
certain things we help you
and uh and
when it comes down later to promote the
movie um let's only talk about how we
helped you
to kind of uh get all the orbits of the
moon right and the space shuttle ride
and all these kind of things
what were some of the with their
involvement i'm imagining they give you
visual assets that you can use to help
make it look more realistic what were
some of the shots that they maybe gave
you footage for well
we couldn't because uh
even their material is not good enough
for us because everything is moving you
know i mean it's like
you cannot like uh when you like for
example go around you know like let's
say you have like uh one side earth and
other side the moon first of all a short
night like this is not existing you know
and then you
there's uh ways to um
uh paint earth you know which looks
totally the real
and then you can do whatever you want
with it and the same thing goes with for
the moon
but they helped us a lot you know
of of super detailed
you know images you know off the moon
you know and uh that was like super
helpful i mean really super helpful
because
normally on on on when you go like on on
the internet you know they're they're
not that detailed
there you have to go like kind of it's
it's like kind of these step-by-step
things you know and uh it's it's
super complicated but it's like that
there they helped us a lot
how does it you
uh
i really like john bradley in this movie
he's very funny he has to deliver the
conspiracy theory he has to he has to do
a lot and he's very good in it had you
been watching game of thrones and said i
want that guy yeah that's how it
happened
well he played
uh samwell and he played him so good and
i saw how he got older and older in the
thing in the five six seven years
uh as long as it was running and he got
like more manly and you know
and this is like kind of really amazing
what he did you know and he always uh
kept everything
it was either emotional or funny
yeah he's very good in the movie you
know he's like an and i kind of said and
i kind of said i i need that guy you
know
how how does it work because i believe
you made this
independently you know you did this on
your own if you will how did how did it
work that's the only thing where
lionsgate has a word into
they're like kind of making their
contract
uh uh
uh you know like a thing we have to be
uh
you know like kind of some sort of
in in casting at least you know well
that's what
you know like 50 50.
well this is what i wanted to ask you
specifically obviously lionsgate is your
partner on this movie i'm not trying to
say lionsgate is not involved they're
clearly very involved how did it work in
terms of the casting
where like did you have ideas of who you
wanted and then who are you bouncing
those ideas off of
well
mainly it's like uh it's in internal uh
centropolis
and uh then you know we go to
you know like kind of to
uh
line skate and have like our you know
like casting meetings and then
we
will like kind of say oh what about this
what about that and they and they're
always like kind of relatively cool
because what they
say is if you have one big name in it
then they're fine
and that's uh was for halle berry
and we also then went to halibury first
because we needed a big name and i i was
like actually
not expecting her to say yes and she
said yes and that was that
you you have a lot of we've talked about
the vfx in this movie what was the shot
or shots that you were like [ __ ] these
are really hard it was all the the
you know the uh the swarm shots
everything with the swarm was like just
a because it was like two companies had
to do it like frame store and d-neck
and they
they like kind of very very very um
[Music]
needed very long to come to a conclusion
how to
make it look so first of all they had
like totally different
predatory
you know like kind of
technical uh way how to do them and they
were totally different that was the
first problem second was uh they had
just like not understood it and then we
had to kind of tell them a little bit
how to to to do them
and uh pete was very involved in that
and we like kind of kept nagging and
nagging on it you know and it was very
very late uh that they finished them i
mean every bose company is very very
late
uh you have a car
chase or a car sequence in changing
gravity in this movie
um talk a little bit about how how do
you script that and how do you design it
um
well that was our um
we wanted to kind of make uh one car
scene which is like super crazy
and and it was like a much more
um wilder even then uh but then we got
like a little bit believability problems
and then we toned it down and turned it
down and at the end
it was like maybe half as long
but actually it was good because
the the people anyway wanted to see more
the the moon inside and uh and what
happens to my our main uh character
then you know um
get broke down by by that but i think
what's now in there is i think is super
great i mean it's like i love it now
because it was way too long i mean it
was just like too long
the inside again this is minor spoilers
uh for people that are watching uh then
you eventually get inside the moon and
there is a superstructure and i'm
curious like how did you actually come
up with the design of that is that
something that you're thinking about are
you working with a production designer
how does that all get figured out there
was like kind of kirk me and
harold and
a guy called johannes muker
and we met the first time uh actually in
in
in mykonos
because it was like just the fastest way
we were like anywhere in my nose and he
then just hopped on the plane
and um
and then we like kind of just had the
first talk about it and that was clear
that there has to be no engine you know
so it has to be like kind of some sort
of uh rings you know which propelled the
moon and balance it out and it was a
we had a whole system you know going and
uh and then we also like kind of said
there has to be like some sort of a um
uh
a grid around it you know because they
there is um
you know like kind of all these
discharges you know then inside are the
three or four
um habitat rings and that
relatively was
created relatively early
donald sutherland is in the movie he has
a small part did he originally have
something bigger was it always just that
little bit was only that scene how was
he apprehensive about taking the role
he's like oh this is my kind of role
first of all he gave us like high notes
on the script
and then he said ah but i cannot do it
and then uh luckily we have like rogue
southerland his son
uh involved in this movie uh he is a
he's a
big agent for independent financing at
cia
and we asked him and say can you not
like convince your dads you know
to make this movie and then he said well
where do they shoot that and you know i
said just outside of your house
because he has a house on the lake which
is like half an hour away from montreal
we were in montreal
and then he like said i'm an oxygen i
cannot do this and then we said look we
can make this happen for you
and
i'm even willing to kind of uh
get in a in a you know like suit you
know and the two operators go into a
suit and uh
and then we can do it and then he said
okay
and then
and then it was back and forth and back
and forth and finally he somewhat we
talked him into it and then uh he was
fantastic i mean oh my god
but an amazing uh actor i mean it was
just amazing and we were a little bit
you know we had kind of uh
i always had the wish to shoot with
donald sutherland
that was my
maybe
that's why i like kind of said i have to
you know i'm even like putting a suit on
you know so you guys just to be clear
when you say suit you mean one of these
like coveted hospitals
and i was like running around with that
all day
uh do you have photos of this no no i
said like no photos got it i just want
to see you in the suit and you know you
know you know no no it's like kind of i
i then didn't even have to really wear
it
but i i for him i was wearing it
you are you read a book that inspired
you to make this you know the conspiracy
theory about the moon uh having
something inside have you read
is there another conspiracy theory that
you've read that you're like oh that
would be a good movie
not really
i also think i have to kind of stop with
the conspiracy theories because um
you know uh q anon is too scary
right i mean
and uh
25 30
of americans believe in that
that's like scary it's it's messed up
it's messed up and they believe that you
know like uh
democrats mainly um
and uh they're like kind of live off the
blood of
human babies
now there has to be a like a shortage of
uh babies around
for that really to happen but you
know it's it's
save the children
[Music]
anyhow
uh i think i would like to open it up to
the audience for a few questions um i
just want to make sure there is nothing
on this sheet that
yeah i have i have something else or two
but i want to open it up um i think we
need the the special imax bubble the
the thing um we'll go here
oh yeah cool hey what's up uh
i think we talked back in september and
i told you how much i liked this movie a
lot with harold uh and speaking of
harold yeah because you were working
with him as your composer for a while he
wrote the movie on this one with you so
has it changed where
now because he's involved in the writing
process he actually starts writing the
move like writing the score or the
themes as you're
shooting well he's uh well when he when
we're writing uh that's the first part
you know there's uh there's nothing he
can do really
but then the moment you know uh i'm
start shooting yeah he like kind of
creates certain themes
plays them to me etc and then slowly
yeah the the
the music score and and then sometimes
he's also totally where i like saying i
don't like that that much i think you
have to go more electronic or you know
that's kind of things and uh
and yeah yeah it's really cool
uh right over here
hey
i still think to this day independence
day is the greatest disaster film ever
made
um
at the la palm hotel in this movie i
couldn't help but notice that the wall
was the carpet from the shining and i
see steve has got the shirt on i don't
know if he noticed that too but i was
just wondering if there was any uh
reason behind that
oh well we're like old fans
you know it's like it was just like a
fan idea you know and sometimes you want
to
you know do a naught to
a great director and you know and you
like kind of plaster your hotel
also with the same wallpaper
cool
i was just going to say real quick i
want to give a shout out to my friend
jenny
who may or may not
are you wave high he may or may not be
in independence day
maybe like uh he this young man was like
you know was in independence day he was
the son of friend equate
i'm sorry jimmy i apologize
we can
we will go right here
uh hi my name is mike my name is my
question was with casey's character
because i know we're on live we can't
say spoilers was this character's arc
always supposed to progress the way it
did
with casey's character
well it's like from the very beginning
uh a character we wanted to kind of take
up there and uh it was always like kind
of this kind of uh
interesting thing you know we like kind
of we had once a scene where he
happily goes up there and then we like
said nah that's like kind of not gonna
work and then uh and i said like maybe
we
go exactly the opposite way you know and
and that was the best version i think
and it was a lot you know to do with
the every man you know who as a kid was
to choppy to you know to to you know be
an astronaut finally can go up there
and uh and yeah and it's like kind of
the fulfillment of his life
before we get to another question i
actually have one for you you've been
you've done 20 something movies now how
has your directing style on set changed
from when you first started to say
making moonfall in terms of are you more
relaxed about storyboards are you more
of looking for more takes or less takes
now how has it has it changed i think i
got a little bit more economic you know
i'm not shooting too much
and um
you know i'm also like
i was at the very beginning i have to
admit the first three four weeks super
super under stress
because that stress just got to me i
mean i was like uh
how will i ever finish this movie right
and um and then actually my
my
first
assistant director was a woman
she like kind of all of a sudden burst
into tears you know and ran away and i
immediately behind her
and then i said what's going on what's
going on she says
nobody and nothing can make you happy
and these people around you they want to
work
for you they would like kill themselves
for you
so
please please be respectful and that
like oh what's like for me
that was like for me uh amazing thing
you know because uh i said i promise you
and then i was relaxed
because i kind of said like look if this
happens or not happens
it's
it's not my
problem really
because i will work as fast as i can and
when we not get it in time then we have
to kind of make maybe cuts or so
but actually we never ever made cuts
to the script oh do you typically like i
know you had 61 days to do this
on average how many takes do you
actually like to do when you're doing
something like this and you know you
have a a limited time to get your shots
well it's like i'm always what i do is
like i shoot a master
and then the master is for me the
rehearsal
you know and there's i make like six
seven eight nine shots of those and
that's it and then
when i'm shooting close up it's only one
or two or three
and uh that's like how i work
and sometimes it's only one shot you
know anyway
you know and uh and
you know and uh for example
um
the good news was uh i had um
i had in the in the uh shuttle i had a
little bit more problems and then i said
to myself let's strap them all in
in the moonlander
and that helped me a lot then to go fast
through it you know what i mean uh and
this was also good for the actors you
know they like kind of were
they didn't saw anything
you know and to to get them
uh you know like kind of worked up and
uh you know like admire what they see
you know you cannot shoot that much
anyway you have a wide shot and then
with
one or two other cameras already
uh the close-ups because you never ever
get that same reaction again
the thing about this is a lot of the
actors on set must be reacting to
nothing um in terms of uh you know like
they're sitting there reacting to the
swarm but they're not it's not actually
there what is what is your direction
when you're talking to say hallie on set
and you're telling her what when the
swarm is there well there's like say
you're like what you do is like you tell
them a little bit it's far away now it's
coming
and you know and but like you don't want
to say too much because that's that's
immediately kind of makes them angry so
it's like you have to kind of just once
explains it explain it really right and
then most of the time they do it right i
mean it's not that they idiots you know
i mean they're super talented actor and
and when sometimes you have to only like
stretch it out
i'm always like saying you have to
stretch it out so
because it takes longer it takes longer
i'm not sure if there's another question
or two otherwise i have more
we're nearing the end so in case anyone
has a last question um you uh you worked
with uh bobby
baumgardner as your dp robbie baumkart i
i'm very bad at i apologize for saying
the name wrong but what actually made
you want to work with him as your dp and
how does it typically work when you're
hiring your crew does it something that
you are like are you interviewing all
these people are you making phone calls
like how does it work when you're
putting together um robbie i met doing
uh independence day resurgence
when i worked with marcus ferdov
and by the way robbie is not german he
has only like maybe german heritage but
so he
doesn't speak one word of german and we
had him as our second dp
you know the guy who first operates you
know but like then
at one point has to split off and do
you know uh
the splinter unit and i'm always running
back and forth between the stages
and um
and uh marcus when he couldn't do the
movie like midway
uh he said to me uh i i said to him
who should i
use as a dp and
he said robbie without even thinking
and he said and i said why because he's
like he's better at lighting than i am
because he was a gaffer before
which naturally is a good thing
and uh because of that you know he he
always like did small movies and i said
why not like using like this uh like
somebody like this for a big movie and
his uh does a super job i mean it's
incredible also he's like extremely fast
he's extremely fast i mean
while i'm like rehearsing with the
actors he's always said i'm finished
because he pre-lights you know he knows
exactly how to pre-light also that no
other lights are in the set you know
then he doesn't only sometimes with a
couple of things you know helps helps it
and um yeah and without him i i without
him i couldn't work that fast
i'm also wondering how happy he was to
book a gig like this and i'm sure he was
thrilled to be working on super like as
fast as he could
yes and he was like kind of
super ambitious too i mean he said like
uh i mean i kind of said like
uh robbie can we shoot this movie
actually i said at the very beginning i
said 59 days and then i kind of said no
so i said in 61 days
and he said uh
let's try
i mean and he was like kind of just
unfazed by it
you you have basically been doing movies
non-stop you don't do a lot of
television i'm curious if in the last
few years with all the streaming and all
the
things if you've thought about
developing like a tv thing that would be
done for eight or ten episodes or
multiple seasons
yeah i mean like we're working right now
on some things called uh dose about to
die
and it's a 10 um our um
show
about um a roman empire and only
concentrates on sports
like in the coliseum oh yeah
circus maximus coliseum you name it
so where how far along are you in the
development of this well we're like kind
of uh we have we just sold the european
rights so that's already a good thing
and we're like out to a lot of american
staff
we'll see what happens is this one of
these things where you might be
directing it or you just produce no i
want to kind of direct
uh at least five or six
really yeah what is your have you been a
uh i'm personally fascinated by roman
history and history in general is this
some like a subject you've had a long
fascination with i was i was actually
once uh
invited uh with dean devlin at that time
after independence day to go to uh you
know like steven spielberg himself
pitched me
all their projects you know
which they had at dreamworks at that
time
and i was listening and listening and
no
gladiator
and i said uh so what about uh this
gladiator thing and he said oh we just
gave this like a week ago or two weeks
ago to ridley
would you like f this
anyhow but look it's like now i'm doing
something which i really love because
there's the underbelly you know it was
like really an underbelly and you see
these like slaves you know like
if they don't get killed and
when they're always like kind of are you
know in danger of being killed and then
some of them
become like a
world-renowned you know one it becomes
like a
dire class and he becomes the most
there's not even uh jordan
you know with his whole air jordan
business is not as rich as he is
as he was
uh he was nearly as as rich and powerful
as the emperor
what's interesting that people might not
realize is the coliseum when you look at
it now you don't really notice it but
below the coliseum was where everything
was not at the beginning really nope so
what was at the beginning because they
wanted to flood it
so
that was then like later by
uh done by uh domitian you know who was
like the second son of uh
vespasian and he um
was at one point like closing down the
coliseum for one or two years and
was sticking in the ground and building
all the
different elevators etc etc before that
they had only like in the around it
you know
around the the second level or third
level and then he just built one um
below the oval
where the scent was
how does it work in terms of uh this is
i mean
this is a very ambitious idea for a
series how does it work in terms of
um in the like are you already scripting
and how does it factor out i have like
the first two scripts
yeah i cannot sell that i was going to
say i'm getting the signal which means
i'm not supposed to ask you any more
questions about this
[Laughter]
i'm just going to say it like this uh
roland i am thrilled that you did this
screening with us i'm so thankful to you
for bringing back the collider imac
screening series with moonfall with you
and a huge thank you to lionsgate and
imax for being awesome partners and to
everyone who came out tonight i want to
say thank you to everyone watching i
want to say thank you and we have really
cool other things coming up and i can't
wait to talk about it and thank you
roland so much
i'm just going to ask for everyone to
remain seated please
and i'm going to ask you to just say
thank you and exit stage right thanks
people
you